busted murders we've taken down cartels
but today we Face the worst New York has
to offer the fire department
Fire Marshal boom We Meet Again
detective Peralta your flies down it
made you look I didn't look and I'm
wearing shorts there is no fly that's
not what your mom said you make no sense
and now I'm inside your head prepare to
die
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and he runs it in I I'd like to see you
score one good because you're about to
see it you're about to see it straight
to hell
[Music]
I'm the king of the world
now cut back to uh the Imperial Star
Destroyer uh Luke uh gets a visit from
and we only show this from the boots up
first so we show these like black boots
with the and then we pan up and oh my
God it's Han Solo but he's old older and
grizzled and really like focused and
cool like he's seen some really bad
stuff and he actually seems shaken and
and Luke is like what's wrong old buddy
and that's when Han drops Chewbacca's
severed head onto the floor yes in front
of all the patterns
let me finish thank you the padawans are
all horrified and uh uh uh Han says that
the planet kashyak has been destroyed by
this very mysterious Force now we know
oh this was Thanos Thanos is beginning
to uh you know gather power in this new
universe so uh while they take Chewie's
head down uh to because we've seen that
you know they can build new bodies
they're going to build Chewie this
really cool robot I I'm thinking spider
body you know like a cool spider body
with Chewie's head and ion cannons on it
but that will be in the he'll come back
that'll be the the post-credits tease of
this film so keep that in mind so I
don't want you guys bummed out because
Chewbacca's not dead he will come back
uh then uh and then honol and then Luke
looks down and Han's wedding ring is
gone hey what happened with you and Leia
and Han's like don't even get me started
on that so now we know where to Leia go
where did Leia go she's not gone but we
will find out the female parts a little
underwritten so far sir I'd like to
point that out I am I'm citizen
filibuster thank you and and really
thank you for respecting Our Town laws
by interrupting me during this uh where
was I yes exactly and the then at the
edge of the
the star destroyer's orbit suddenly the
time ribbon begins uh wavering and what
comes through the X-Men's quinjet that's
right what we did was back on Earth we
showed him Gathering up all the heroes
but we didn't see him Gathering up the
X-Men so oh my goodness now Wolverine's
going to be there now Cyclops is going
to be there so the quinjet comes through
Luke gets in his X-Wing to go out and
meet them and they engage in this
awesome Star Battle and it looks like
the quinjet actually is going to shoot
Luke down and suddenly this volley of
lasers comes in and and what comes
flying in is we think it's going to be
it we think it's going to be the
Millennium Falcon just like in episode
four when he comes in and saves him uh
during the Battle of Yavin but no it is
slave one that's right Boba Fett [ __ ]
ship slave one has to save Luke because
of course he's trying to track down Han
he can't have Luke die so then now it's
a battle between the quinjet between the
X-Wing between slave one and then uh we
see that Millennium Falcon uh is flying
away so uh now um a slave one goes off
to to do that but then then we cut down
to corsicon where uh uh Princess Leia uh
is now Consulting with um uh with Lando
Calrissian now it looks like they're
just having a very intense meeting about
trade regulations and about I will not I
will not finish my speaking about trade
regulations and and but then suddenly
once when the rest of the council
meeting leaves they fall into each
other's arms oh my God Lando Calrissian
and Princess Leia are having an affair
and that is why Han Solo because look
Lando Calrissian was like hey if I'm
going to lose the Millennium Falcon to
you I'll just take your woman and he has
so then we set that triangle up now cut
back to the quinjet and read Richard
from the Fantastic Four is piloting it
oh it was a fake out he it's him and we
have select members of the X-Men that I
thought in my opinion were um were not
uh focused on properly in the earlier
films we have Colossus in there we have
x-23 uh which is Wolverine's daughter
and then we have a now mind controlled
Sabretooth and of course Wolverine so
imagine those two going up against robot
Chewbacca because that's going to happen
that is what we're teasing right now I
have literally have no fluid in my mouth
I got to do a Marco Rubio can we please
cut
oh
attention everyone I've got the new
music teacher here so start getting to
know him by uh you know telling them
about yourself and all your hardships
pump the brakes here Hell on Wheels
Songbird can carry his own tune
it is happening at long last we are
being Undercover Boss what does that
mean that means whoever tells Durbin the
biggest Love Story gets a cash prize one
of us is getting twenty thousand dollars
but you gotta pretend like you don't
know it's him
my face hurts
Steph Duncan history
and that's why we know that he's so
creative we
uh Jojo and I've danced with Lady music
and every dress she can wear saw a lot
of naked ladies with the boys and They
Might Be Giants and banged a lot of they
might have been Giants with the bare
naked ladies you name a song I've played
it Piano Man all that stuff you know
what I'm still grateful what are you
grateful for Steph oh plenty of things
unlike the orphans that I take canoeing
you know my dream is to take them to
Disney World and let them ride the log
flume the world's best canoe but that'd
be like 20K
it's gone up well righteous buzz kill
about the uh orphans not having any
rents I mean do you uh recall a
particular orphan that maybe talked
about wanting to eat a ton of shrimp
Helen there you are is this the man
who's going to be replacing me
16 years and I gotta hear about it in
the hallway
s
turning the heads up
put myself on fire okay oh Hey listen
I'm not into that all right
self-immolation is a JoJo no no so I'm
I'm gonna go talk to this cool cat
Durbin and I'm gonna Stone Cold resign
and and then I'll I'll leave to a
different door so you'll probably never
see me again so uh you know remember you
can lick the devil's candy but don't get
in his van
all right